ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BONTA ANSWER
MANY PLEASE SIR PRESENT
YOURSELF MORE OUTLETS SO ALICE
COOPER'S MEMBERS WERE UP TO
CHEER RIGHTS IF YOU HEAR ACOSTA
CHILDCARE FOUND HERE AND HERE I
CAN HEAR FLORA LEE MOST PARENTS
LIMON HERE MCCARTY MELENDEZ
MULLIN IS HERE AND IF YOU'RE
CURIOUS HERE SOUND HERE WE HAVE
A QUORUM MISTER BONTA THINGS
WHICH I THINK YOU CALLING FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT AB
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR I PERSONALLY
THINK CHAIR STAFF FOR ALL
THE WORK YOU GUYS BUT I WAS
RESULTS OF THE THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE WORK IN THE SUGGESTIONS
IN YOU THAT I AND HAVE A
PROJECT THAT WILL ALLOW SPORTS
YOU KNOW STAY THERE INCLUDED
THERE YEARS AND ONCE THAT WE'RE
NEW STADIUM MAKES CARING FOR
THE HOME FOR THE LONG TERM
FUTURE ALLOWS THEM TO STEP
AND IT'S A IT'S A PROJECT
THAT IS PRIVATELY FINANCED
IT HAS A LOT OF ITS LATE
BENEFIT FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT HOUSING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING A LOT OF
TRIMMING BENEFITS AND THE MAIN
BENEFIT OF THIS BILL IS THAT
WHILE FULLY COMPLYING WITH
SEQUENCE KILEY AND THE I.
R.
AND ALL OF THE -- OF
REQUIREMENTS THURMOND IT ALLOWS
FOR AN EXPEDITED JUDICIAL
REVIEW PROCESS FOR TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY DAYS THIS PROVIDES
GREATER CERTAINTY FOR A PROJECT
OF THIS SIZE ALLOWS FOR FOR
PLANNING AND AND LAWS TO GET
A PATH FOR SUCCESSFUL PROJECT
I JUST WANNA HOW A COUPLE OF
THE MAIN AREAS WHERE -- FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP
IS IS HIGHLIGHTED THROUGH
THIS BILL A COMMITMENT TO
LEGAL CERTIFICATION FOR THE
ENTIRE PROJECT A NET ZERO
GHG EMISSIONS TWENTY PERCENT
TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS
ONE NEAR COMPLETION NOBODY
HAD HUNDRED HAD A FIFTEEN
PERCENT -- TARGET SO WE GO
ABOVE EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED
AND ADDITIONAL GHG LOCATION
MEASURES THAT WILL ENSURE FIFTY
PERCENT OF THE PRODUCTION OUR
DIRECTOR OF LOCAL THERE MAY
BE FIFTY PERCENT S.
B.
OFFSETS HOW DO WITH THESE
REQUIREMENTS -- WHEN LOOKING
FORWARD TO IT OF THE DAYTON
CITY OPENED RETRAINING AND
REAFFIRMING -- AND EXTENDING
A HAND TO FIND THEIR
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP
AND ARE PROBABLY ON THIS
ISSUE AND HAD WE BEFORE YOU
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO WEAR
THIS BILL FORWARD AND CREATE
A NEW STADIUM IN OAKLAND
WHILE ALSO TECHNICIAN VETTING
STANDING FIRM FARM IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION COLLEGE
ESPECIALLY AFTER I BROKE
SENATOR THURMOND IS HERE WITH
ME AS THAT COOPER AND HAS A
MARKET IS A FEW SIMILAR THANK
CHAIRMAN LEE I KEEP IT BRIEF
-- SOMETHING SIGNIFICANT
OFFER ON SEVEN THIRTY FOUR MY
COLLEAGUE FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
UP THIS IS MORE THAN A BASEBALL
STADIUM ON THIS BASEBALL
TEAM REPRESENTS THE HEART OF
THE CITY EVERY SEND THEM OFF
AND I -- SHARE OAK AND WHILE
THE STATE OF SIX IN ONE PART
IMAGINE EVERY PART OF OUR
REGION SURROUNDING OAKLAND
FEELS THAT THIS IS THEIR AND
AS YOU HEARD THIS REGION IS
CONNECTED WITH SYMBOLICALLY AND
POLITICALLY AND ECONOMICALLY
AND WE ARE HONORED TO HAVE
PARTNERS WHO WANT TO BUILD A
CITY LECTURING HIM FOR THIS
COMMUNITY AT A TIME OTHERS
HAVE CHOSEN TO ABANDON THIS
AND THESE PARTNERS YOU HEAR
FROM TONIGHT ALSO RESPECT THAT
WE MUST DO THIS IN A WAY THAT
IS ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND FOUR
HOURS IN PLACES NO FUNDING
GRADED ON THEM ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDPOINT HOW THEY WILL CREATE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY IT DRIVES
HOME THE POINT THAT WE OBSERVE
HAVE BEEN FINAL ADVOCACY AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT DO NOT
HAVE MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE THIS
PROJECT BY THE FACT THAT YOU
HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUE IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF IT WOULD
HOUSING FOR A REGION THAT HAS
BEEN BADLY HIT BY THE HOUSING
MARKET BECAUSE OF PUBLIC BEYOND
WHAT'S EXPECTED OF EIGHTY
NINE HUNDRED FACT IS IN NEW
TRANSPORTATION OPPORTUNITIES
AND OFFSET REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS ABSTRACT WE ASK
YOU FOR THIS CUTTING EDGE OF
PARTNERSHIP AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
OAKLAND WITH US THE TESTIFIED
BEFORE IT IS OPEN MAYOR LEACH
OUT WHEN MAYES PRESIDENT THEY'D
HAVE A AND FROM THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY BUILDING FACE BROUGHT
GOOD EVENING CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING TEHRAN
MY JOB IT'S ALL YOU WHY
THE OF OAKLAND
WITH THE PRIVILEGE
WE ARE THE NAME
OAKLAND EIGHT IF
UNLESS THE MAYOR OF
SOMEONE WHO HAS TAKEN
ON FIGHTING A COLD TERM
READ CONVICTION YOU CAN TRUST
TO ENSURE THAT THIS PROJECT
NOT JUST THE BALLPARK BUT THE
ENTIRE PROJECT IS GOING TO
MEET THE HIGHEST ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS AS WELL AS OUR
VALUES AROUND RESPECTING
WORKER PROVIDING DESPERATELY
NEEDED AFFORDABLE HOUSE THE
CITY OF OAKLAND HAS A LONG
OF THIS TYPE OF ADVOCACY AND
THESE TYPES OF VALUES AND AS
THE MAYOR I ASSURE YOU THAT
THIS PARTNERSHIP IS VERY CLEAR
ABOUT HOW WE WILL SATISFY THOSE
COMMUNITY VALUES AND AGAIN
WE APPRECIATE THE SUGGESTION
THAT YOU HAVE PUT INTO THIS
BILL TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT THIS SIXTEEN EIGHTY
NINE HUNDRED STANDARDS AND
THAT THIS IS A PROJECT THAT
WE WILL ALL BE I STAND READY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND
I RESPECT WE ASK EVERYONE'S
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF CHAIRMAN
IT'S REALLY AN HONOR TO BE HERE
WERE CELEBRATING FIFTY YEARS
OF HEALTH PLAN ELIMINATES WE
HAVE A GREAT HISTORY OF AMAZING
PLAYERS WHETHER IT'S CATFISH
HUNTER RICKY HENDERSON AND BY
THE BLUE FOR THE PLAYERS ON THE
CURRENT TEAM NAJAT NAMED SEAN
AND I WISH YOU KNOW HERE THIS
YEAR WE WANT TO HAVE ANOTHER
FIFTY OR A HUNDRED YEARS AND
THE CRITICAL WAITED YOU THAT
IS WE HAVE A NEW PRIVATE THE
FINE THAT WILL PUT FLORA AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE OBVIOUSLY VERY HIGH
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS WHICH
I THINK THIS BILL PROVIDES
WITH YOUR HELP WE CRAFTED
SOMETHING THAT I THINK CAN
BE A WIN WIN THAT WE CAN
BRING THE PRIVATE FINANCING
HIGH ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT CRITICS
INCLUDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND A PROJECT THAT CAN BE WIN
FOR THE ENTIRE REGION AND SO
WE'RE EXCITED TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THAT HE NEEDS A LOT FOR
US TO KNOW THAT WE HAVE THE
CERTAINTY OF THIS LEGISLATION
CRITICAL TO ITS FINANCIAL
SUCCESS AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
I OF WORK I THINK WE'RE ALL
EXCITED TO HAVE A YOU END UP
MAYOR SHAFIR BUT I WAS HOPING
TO HAVE THE REGGIE JACKSON
SENATE
FOR NDA DROPPED OVER
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PROJECT
-- ROB SUPER WITH THE ALAMEDA
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL I
DON'T YOUR MEMBERS AS OF
YET FATALLY ALSO QUAYLE IS
FOR THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE JOB
THANK YOU MY QUESTION JUST
A COUPLE SIXTEEN PAID IT NO
TREATMENTS FROM JERRY BROWN
SURE JASON BRIAN DOWNTOWN
OAKLAND BUSINESS IMPROVEMENT
DISTRICT JACK LONDON BUSINESS
THERE ISN'T ONE SIR KEEP
DINER FOR DISCOUNTS MICHAEL'S
MISTER CHAIRMAN POLITICAL
IF YOU HAVE THE MAYOR
AND REBUILD AMERICA WHAT
JOHN HANNAH HERE
FOR THE SOUTHWESTERN
ALRIGHT ANY -- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS PROJECT
PLEASE COME FOR MOVING THAT
VAMP HOME FROM THE SHOW
COMES ON THE OPPOSITION
AS YOU HEARD EARLIER ON
WE'RE NOT HERE TO DEBATE THE
MERITS PROJECT ARE FROM SO WE
ON THE OVERALL CHARGE TO OUR
COURT SYSTEM TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING PEOPLE ACCESS
WALDRON GETS PUBLICLY SOCCER
TEAMS BILLS THE PROBLEM FEES
FOR THOSE FOR US IS THAT THEY
PUT TO THE FRONT OF THE LINE
OVER ALL OTHER CASES ONLY FORCE
GOT KICKED OUT OF YOUR MIND
FOR PUBLIC TRUST AND CONFIDENCE
AND JUSTICE SYSTEM DONE TO
TRY TO PROVIDE FOR A PARTIAL
SENATE FOR THOSE REASONS
OKAY SO IN THE SPIRIT OF TRYING
TO -- -- I HAVE HEARD THAT
THE QUICK AND EFFICIENT --
MEETING I WE JUST HAD A EARLIER
HEARING ON A VERY SIMILAR --
CONCEPTUALLY SOBRE PROPOSAL THE
CLIPPERS ARENA JUST -- -- AN
HOUR TO AGO AND -- JUST JUST
KIND OF AYE AYE DAHLE GIVEN
OVER HERE OF COURSE OPEN UP TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO WORK
-- EXPRESS YOUR OWN OPINIONS
ARE ASKING QUESTIONS BUT -- I
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT
FOR A GOOD NUMBER OF US -- YOU
KNOW -- MAYOR CHEF WE WE HAVE
NO DOUBT THAT -- THAT YOU WERE
I HAVE STRONG ENVIRONMENTAL
VALUES BUT THERE ARE OUR ISSUE
IS THAT MANY OF US HATE THESE
ONE OFF BILLS WILL BECOME A
ONE OFF BILLS -- WHERE WE'RE
MAKING SPECIAL EXCEPTIONS FOR
FOR SPECIAL APPLICANTS -- THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAS A RIGHT
TO THINK THEY MAKE A VERY
IMPORTANT POINT TO YOU KNOW WE
DON'T LIKE TO YOU KNOW OF --
NO SWAY FROM THE EQUAL JUSTICE
FOR ALL PRINCIPLE OF WE HAVE A
PROCESS AB NINE HUNDRED WE'RE
HOPING THAT THE AIDS WOULD GIVE
A FOLLOW AB NINE HUNDRED BETTER
THE ARGUMENTS WERE MADE THAT
-- THIS DESERVE SO BASICALLY
SPECIAL TREATMENT AND -- AND SO
ARE MANY BUT STRUGGLED WITH S.
AND AND SOME -- MAY BE OPPOSED
TO THIS -- THIS BILL TONIGHT
BETTER YOU KNOW ABOVE AS A
MISTER BONTA MISSIVE THURMOND
INDICATED -- WE BELIEVE THAT
THANKS TO THE NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE TEAM AND DEATH AND
WHAT THEY'RE COMMITTEE STAFF
-- THAT WE OR I IN MANY
WAYS -- BEEN ABLE TO ACHIEVE
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS THAT
GO ABOVE AND BEYOND EIGHTY NINE
NINE HUNDRED AND UP FOR THAT
REASON I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL -- BUT I CANNOT TELL
AND WILL NOT GUARANTEE THAT
THE REST OF THE COMMITTEE WILL
SUPPORT THIS BILL ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OF MUSIC YEAH THE
PART OF ME KNOWING THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE SITTING HERE -- I
SHARE THE CONCERNS THAT YOU
HAVE BUT ALSO HAVE FEES FOR
TONIGHT COM AND ALSO SAY IS
EXCEPTION MISTER STONE IS THE
ONLY OTHER NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
IF THE AIDS LEGAL BE
TOO EASY FOR THE GIANTS
TO THE NUMBER ONE TEAM
DODGERS
PROVE THAT WELL
YOU BY ONE OF THE
MOST OF THE MADE BY MS SECOND
I MISSED I AM -- JUST QUICKLY
I PRETTY CLEAR ON MY RECORD OF
VOTING AGAINST THESE I THINK
YOU GOT A GREAT PROJECT I WOULD
HOPE THE ENVIRONMENTAL BELIEVE
THAT HOUSING ALL OF THOSE GIVEN
OPEN TRACK RECORD WOULD BE A
PART OF ANY PROJECT'S ANYWAY
AND THE BASIC PROBLEM HAVE
WITH THESE KINDS OF BILLS AND
SABRES THERE'S AN UNDERLYING
ASSUMPTION THAT HE WAS NOT
WORKING SICK WAS BROKEN I DON'T
BUY THAT IT'S A POPULAR CONCEPT
THAT THAT I DISAGREE WITH
SO I HOW I WOULD EXPECT THIS
PROJECT TO HAVE ALL OF THOSE
BENEFITS ANYWAY AND SO FOR US
TO DO FEES ONE OFFS AND THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY REPRESENT
COULDN'T STAY WITH MY PATTER
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
ALRIGHT SO -- THE CHAIRS
RECOGNITION IS AYE BUT --
WE ARE ALL GOING TO VOTER
CONSCIOUS -- MADAM SECRETARY
LESSER ANY OTHER FURTHER IS
OUR MOTION YET MOTIONS AND MADE
AND SECONDED LA HOPE MISTER
BONTA OR IN THIS THURMOND WAS
LIKE THOSE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT THAT'S RIGHT
IT FOR THE QUESTION FROM THE
DISCUSSION -- YOU KNOW THE WE
REALLY CONCERNS AND AND AND I
YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE SHARE THAT AND I THINK
THAT SORT OF OUR RESPONSE
TO THAT WAS TO GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND EVEN TO BREAK NEW GROUND
PIONEER NEW ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMITMENTS AND YOU KNOW THAT
THAT THAT THAT LAYS AND THE
CITY OF OAKLAND THIRTEEN IS A
CERTAINTY THIS YEAR PETERBILT
MOMENTUM COMMUTER TARGET HAVING
ANYTHING ABOUT TWENTY THREE AND
THIS WILL REALLY HELP US GET
THERE SO WE REALLY RISK EXPECT
WE HAVE TO AYE VOTE THANK YOU
I WAS SIMPLY STATING THAT THE
CHAIR STAFF OR THE WAY YOU
APPROACH THIS TO HELP GET -- I
I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAVENS
COMMENTS -- REALLY SYMBOLIZE
HAVE THIS TEAM MORE THAN JUST
THE CITY ITS ITS IMPACT IS
FELT VERY DEEPLY THROUGHOUT
THE REGION FOR THOSE OF YOU
DON'T WANT TRIES TO -- I HAVE
HAD SUCH SPENDING ON HEALTHCARE
NMSIIS VOTE I I SWEAR MICHIGAN
SUPER HOT HOT HOT HOT HOT
MEMBERS
I EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE FLORA
LARA I'M LIMON LIMON NO
MELENDEZ WHEN IS NOT VOTING
FRANCE I RENTS AYE STONE
THAT DON'T KNOW SIX TWO SIX
TO THE BILL ITSELF HELLO
ALL RIGHT NOW BUT THAT
PASSED IT'S AROUND